yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights visit
expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
i want to make it easier for people to
get married and have kids
in this country and the number one
reason in 2018
that we had the lowest marriage rate of
all time was
not having the funds not you know
irreligiosity secularization
any of that which is something that is
erroneously blamed
by in my view like libertarian
conservatives
on people when in reality it's what
you're talking about it's the
cruelty of an economic system which
makes it so that you are not
living up and making the choices that
you want to make it should be a giant
red flag to all of us if you have the
lowest lowest marriage rates because of
economic
insecurity the lowest child bearing
rates because of economic insecurity
you talk to a young person and they look
up and say
i don't know if i'm ever going to be
able to settle down anywhere and have a
kid because i can barely
like pay off my debt and keep a roof
over my head to me
right now our goal should just be human
flourishing and i agree with you that
most most all the time the best way to
have people flourish is to put the
agency in their hands
and let them make their own decisions
it's yet another cross over the great
sagar and jetty from the hill
is going to be on yank speaks and i'm
going to be on the realignment thank you
andrew so much for joining the podcast
really appreciate it man
appreciate you you man i thought you
were young i didn't realize you were as
young as you are
[Laughter]
well you're a young man you know you're
a young man i'm not young like you man i
mean you're freaking
late 20s late 20s to mid 40s when you're
in your late 20s
you can stay up to all hours you can put
anything you want
in your body you can court injury and
know that you'll
you'll bounce back so i appreciate you
lumping me in with yourself
and in that category but i remember my
late 20s
and there's a difference
[Laughter]
so andrew tell me about your mid let's
start there actually tell me about your
mid-20s like
how did you ideologically kind of come
to where you are right now because you
know just quick context like on my
podcast and i know we have
some similar missions here but mine is
really just looking at the realignment
in american politics you've always kind
of embodied that you know
huge amount of crossover with trump
voters and more
and the number one question i often get
and that's one of the one i wanted to
hear from you
is how did you kind of come to see what
was happening
in this country you wrote your book
before obviously you ran for your
candidacy
but how many years before that did you
kind of see that you know the fourth
industrial revolution kind of happening
before your eyes
well it took a lot of walking around the
country
um over the last now gosh nine years or
so
but i used to compare it to the parable
of the blind men and the elephant where
you ask
the blind uh what does an elephant look
like and then one of them's holding the
trunk and it's like a big thick snake
and another one's touching the leg and
saying like a tree trunk
so in in my case i spent that seven
years traveling the country
for an organization that i started
venture for america that took me to
detroit cleveland baltimore st louis
birmingham new orleans and cities around
the country and i saw the aftermath
of automation and manufacturing jobs
and it was like a sledgehammer i was
walking around these places being like
wow this place is not doing well
uh and and it it struck me that's like
why is it that
we're not we don't seem to be having
like an honest
grappling with what it means to decimate
manufacturing communities to this
degree so i'm
a an entrepreneur in a practical type so
for me you know the the interesting
trajectory i've had is that you try and
solve one problem and then it leads you
to another problem and then it leads you
to another problem so
for me the problem i was trying to solve
for seven years was that we weren't
creating enough new businesses and
entrepreneurship
and business growth and job growth in
communities around the country
and then i realized that the problems
were much bigger and deeper
but certainly andrew yang in his late
20s was not thinking any of this andrea
in his late 20s was just
you know trying to get a date i think
what's interesting and what captured so
many
so much interest about your candidacy
and and more was
you didn't talk you talk about it in
terms of the fourth industrial
revolution obviously you know we've i've
interviewed you in the past and you
obviously understand
some of the deeper i mean obviously you
did the math but
you also spoke about it in a very
visceral way so when you were traveling
those places
and you're talking to these people how
did it come through like in their
stories
because something that i've always kind
of come to understand is that
elite economists and many others will
try to explain phenomena away by being
like no your job is gone but you
you're better off because of x and that
when you actually talk to real voters
and people who have been you know
affected by
automation trade policy or lock last
loss of manufacturing they know exactly
why they lost their job
and the macro force that it kind of
brought about so
is that something that you saw like
whenever you were traveling
yeah they did know what happened
particularly in a place like detroit
where
the urban center emptied out for the
most part
and the population drained away uh
and they know that it was a combination
of globalization and trade deals and
offshoring and also
the automation of many of their
traditional manufacturing jobs so they
know
and i studied economics so
i understand the theory behind it uh you
know like oh comparative advantage
you'll be fine or you know you'll
learn how to do something that's higher
value add but then you go there and that
stuff just seems
farcical you know you go there right
and there was a disconnect that
uh i struggled with and then trump won
in 2016. i started adventure of america
in 2011. so i've been doing that work
for five years
and then trump wins and then i'm like
okay uh this is much deeper and nastier
and we're still we're still not being
honest about it somehow so
that that was what drove me but i i am
very interested in trying to figure out
the genesis of my
um uh of my approach in part because
like i i went to brown university which
most people know that's like a very
liberal
uh college um but
uh you know i've been an operator and
entrepreneur for
20 years or so uh and
you know they're just like facts on the
ground that you have to deal with and if
you
tell yourself a nonsense story and
you're running a private company
uh you're going to fail like it's it's
you know it's inevitable and so
you know i like to think i just traffic
in uh
as close a version of reality as i can
find uh because if if you're
operating from reality then you're more
likely to be successful
and one of the frustrations i found
sauger is that like
there's not a whole lot of trafficking
in reality that's going on right now
uh and it's going to destroy us because
we have this increasingly
in kuwait uh set of arguments
and one thing that someone said to me is
lawrence lessig
who said to me that we live in a
vetocracy right now where
i can't get anything done but i can keep
you from getting anything done right
and and so there's a lot of negative
power going on um
and we're in an era of unprecedented
change
and so if you freeze government and say
no one can get anything done then you
wind up with
problems that just get bigger and bigger
and you become more and more behind the
curve and out of date
i think that's a really profound point
that you're making there andrew because
the
the main thing that you're observing is
that we can
stop things from other getting done and
like i was saying like i generally find
the whole shtick
about businessmen trying to run the
country that way
as pretty hokey because it's like well
no actually like a nation state it's not
a business and all that
but the one thing where i think it
absolutely does apply is to your point
was
is that if you keep if you do something
which is totally delusional
you generally your business should fail
like there should be at least some sort
of incentive theoretically that's in
democracy
like voters should vote you out if you
do fail and yet
we've kind of come to a system where you
have both parties which are
invested very much in an ideology which
has failed you know the fourth
industrial revolution as you call it
didn't really just occur
out of nowhere how did we get to that
point how do you think that the
political system itself
got broken to the point where it's
generally
impervious to the will of actual voters
i'm digging into this more and more
sagar which is why
why are we so detached from our leaders
or vice versa
and there are all of these layers
between the people and
our policy makers at this point and you
can go through them successively
i mean number one is if if an ordinary
person tries to run for office they have
no chance of doing so because
they're going to need a million bucks
and the average human being is not going
to be able to go get a million bucks to
try and unseat
the incumbent and then they're you know
you might be in a district
where it's safe red or safe blue so your
only
option is to primary the incumbent
which itself has some obstacles if
you're fortunate enough to
actually get into office then you're
in a constant fundraising hamster wheel
where you're just constantly
calling folks and dialing for dollars
and then the system serves as your moat
where you're like okay now if i dial for
dollars diligently
i now have a million dollar moat between
me and anyone who's going to challenge
me
you have this entire layer of corporate
interest that then get in your ear and
tell you what they think you should do
and when you're in dc
they're the only people that you'll
actually talk to uh there was an onion
headline that was funny it was
the american people should hire uh our
own lobbyists
to represent us on capitol hill and you
laugh but i was like that's a pretty
good idea
we should just have a lobbyist being
like you know what americans think
um because at this point you have a
lobbyist for every other major trade
group or set of industries
telling you what they think and then you
get into
congress and your incentives are not to
reach across the aisle and get anything
done
because you know you might be in again
in a seat
where it's not serving the general
public
that is in your political interest it's
just to try and keep yourself from
getting primaried
because of the way the districts have
been drawn so your job
isn't necessarily to solve the work of
the public
or solve the problems of the public and
do the people's work
uh it's to raise enough money so you
never lose
uh to avoid getting primaried to avoid
any scandal so don't do anything that's
going to put you into harm's way
you know i guess some of them can't pull
that one off and then
to get your face on cable news you can
build a better public profile
and then maybe try and advance yourself
politically
and one of the things i was for on the
campaign trail was for
earmarks because they helped people
reach across the island get deals done
and so if i wanted to
try and pass this law and then you said
look i can get on board with this law if
you
you know help fund my bridge or museum
or whatever it is
i think that's fine you know and then
people could look at it and say that
bridgette museum is a waste it's like is
it really i mean you know someone wanted
it
like you're a member of congress thought
it was a good idea uh so there
there are these fundamental structural
problems that keep
legislators from carrying what we think
but a big part of it
sauger is the media where the media is
not really holding anyone
accountable to a uniform set of facts
anymore there's just this
back and forth news of the day uh and
the rise and fall of many characters
uh so that that there is like an
increased level of
uh both confusion and despair among the
average american and so a lot of
americans just check out politics
altogether and say well this is a waste
of time i couldn't agree with you more i
mean you know i've been i'm obsessed
with this study from the knight
foundation called like the hundred
million project and they
look at the reason the 100 million
people in america who don't vote and why
they don't vote it's like a broad cross
section and
the number one reason why is apathy with
the political system they have
no faith in both political in all
political institutions in business
institutions and all of the
general institutions of american life so
when they look at voting i mean i love
this
i think there was a story from 2016 from
a barber shop in milwaukee
a black barber shop and they actually
went in and people said you know i
didn't vote and i don't really feel bad
about it
here on yank speaks we are all about
your data rights
prop 24 is about to pass in california
thanks to you and it's going to set a
new
new threshold for how our data gets
treated but in the meantime your data is
getting
sold and resold right and left and even
your internet service providers know
every move you make so what can you do
you can use
a virtual private network which is what
all the companies
have their employees do and the vpn we
recommend
is the number one rated by cnet wired
and the verge expressvpn
expressvpn it's like you log into a
server
on another continent and no one knows
it's you
no one knows what the heck you did so if
you
want your data to remain secure
expressvpn is what you've been looking
for
secure your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
yang today there's a special deal where
you get three months for free and your
subscription
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang
[Applause]
you focus in there on the media and i
know you're really into
as i am as well kind of what the future
of media
might look like and i'm really
fascinating andrew because you
came up i mean you got popular on
independent media joe rogan
on my show and many other different
places across the internet but now
you're
kind of in the way down
[Laughter]
but now you're in the belly of the beast
you're on cnn you're on these cnn kind
of post election panels so just talk to
us about that
like you are someone who looks very much
at future the media how it can be solved
also kind of working within cnn
what's that like
well i certainly went through this media
ringer uh and i appreciate you and
crystal
um and folks like joe and sam harris
uh and so many others breakfast club
that had me on when i was
not as mainstream i suppose and just
heard me out
and talked about my campaign
uh now being on cnn like i have more
insight
into the goods and bads of how the media
works
and i've been honest saying look
for me being on cnn i think is very
positive because it helps
just get my face and voice in front of
uh americans in a way that can help
advance our
goals and ideas and i will say being on
cnn
i have never gotten any notes
in terms of hey maybe you should try and
make this point or
feedback being like hey that point was
not great
or go down this direction so you know
on that level um it's quite positive
but i also see that there are incentives
wrapped up
in the medium that end up driving
coverage in particular ways
and that the medium doesn't allow for
particular
types of conversations or ideas to get
out that might
not fit into the rhythm of a five-minute
cable news hit uh that in those news
hits comprise the vast majority
of the coverage because the thought is
that well if you're a tv audience like
you need to keep things snappy and then
kind of get in and out and
you have like graphic and video and some
other stuff
so i i let's just say that you know
being part of the media
is just fueling my desire to try to
change the incentives in ways that'll
make it work better for
more americans and i i say this
in particular about the thousand plus
local newspapers that went out of
business so are there issues with cable
news yes
major issues uh but at least they exist
you know if you have no local paper it's
very hard
to vote on what's going on in your town
and so what's going on in media is a is
a microcosm of what
is going wrong in american life which is
just the market
runs everything and so if you're like
post office doesn't make money
[ __ ] the post office you know like uh
that local paper didn't make money
anymore
get rid of it it's like well maybe that
local paper actually had some value to
the people in that town
beyond the fact that it made uh money as
a private
concern uh so i'm after in a big way
sagar because
to me we have to fix democracy and and
it's going to be difficult to fix
democracy if you don't have
certain types of functioning media
organizations yeah and
let's talk about the incentives there
because we've talked a lot here on you
know on my podcast just about the way
that the media business is changing you
know you have
first you had the click ad revenue model
of course there was a monopoly on
classified ads
now that's gone with facebook google and
so much more i actually
use a line all the time that you think
you said on my show which is that the
internet naturally
selects from monopolies like nobody
wants to use the fourth worst google
the second best facebook or whatever but
it so
if we're going to live within that
system with realities and i've always
appreciated that you're fair
right that you know people actually
people don't really want to use multiple
facebooks or multiple googles
if we're going to use if we're going to
live in that world what do we do with
media so because how do we actually make
it so because you don't want
government subsidized local news either
i mean that you know
we're talking about earmarks and pork
like i actually do want and this is
where we disagree i do want i think
that's
subsidized local news yeah but how would
you protect it
um how would you protect it from you
know
legislators who are using it as a
bargaining chip like if you look at
what's happening right now with voice of
america
and the global news um agency there have
been all these accusations like oh
trump put in this person and you know
even though this person has been
selected by congress so if we were going
to fund it like what are the ways that
we could do it
while keeping it independent with the
essential role that media has
and then also protecting it from
political influence is it even possible
i think it is possible and i think that
there are
a few different parties that need to be
part of it
number one is government number two is
uh
nonprofits and ngos and then number
three are the the media companies
and i think there's a way you can fund
it where let's say hypothetically you
said guess what
getting quality information about what's
going on in your community
is a public good and we're just going to
say that there's a certain amount of
money that gets allocated
for every congressional district based
on population
and there's going to be like a local
paper that ends up being the beneficiary
of this
or like a local station or whatever like
the local organs are
and it could be public private uh you
know it could even be in some cases
philanthropic
uh but that there are different
approaches these media organizations
could
100 exist if they weren't forced to
throw off
market level profits every given quarter
so what do i mean by that it's like look
my local paper can't compete
but if you had a combination public
private and you had a paper that made a
certain amount of money and then spent
that much
money on coverage and it broke even
every year
obviously no one would invest in that
because you know it's a terrible
business
but uh as the public would you invest in
that probably i mean you'd
you know you'd put it in place and then
at least you don't have to mess it and
in my mind it would be worth the subsidy
i have no problem with subsidizing
uh local journalism and i also think
sagar this is a fundamental issue
um and this is where i possibly and i
think i'm clear-headed about this
genuinely
this is probably where you and i
disagree well conservatives look up and
say
hey you can't have government involved
with local media because it'll become
politicized and a bargaining chip
and they might influence coverage etc
etc and then i look at it and say okay
the current situation is literally zero
like can you improve on zero
uh and if you have issues around
politicization and the rest of it you
can look around the world and say
look are there independent media
organizations that are publicly funded
that seem like they're okay criticizing
the government and you would find yes
they do exist
you know you could hold up the bbc as
one potential example and say that
is it perfect no but does it exist and
do a lot of people
get value from it and like does it seem
fairly
independent journalistically and able to
critique leaders yeah
sure uh and so the the
the correct approach is not in my
opinion just throw up your hands and say
can't do it like government's going to
screw it up somehow
instead you have to get into the weeds
of it and say look
like the current path is leading towards
in this case
total absence of local journalism which
i would argue is very disastrous for it
for democracy
so then you have to just put your hard
hat on and roll up your sleeves and say
okay what are the issues we're concerned
about
you don't want politicians being able to
yank funding every time that the
the news organization says something
nasty about them well then like
let's see if we can make this funding
mechanism independent uh
of of congress's whims maybe you have
like very long time frames or you can
only make changes like x years in
advance when
you know like like it might not matter
to you anyway
right uh so like that to me is like a
more
uh principled approach um but and this
is the tough truth as someone who and
it's fun because i know some people like
me
because they think i have some
libertarian impulses and leanings and
whatnot
um like i am very conscious of the fact
that there are a lot of things in my
opinion government is terrible at
and you'd rather not have them involved
with it but
there there's also this tough truth that
we're in an era where
you're going to need government at a
minimum to inject resources
into certain types of institutions or to
solve certain types of problems because
there's so many problems we have
that the market will not have any
interest in solving so i actually
completely agree with you and you know
people
you know who know me know that it's not
about the government intervention
necessarily that
i'm most concerned about it's actually
that i'm not
so sure that we don't have a private
sector solution and
the reason i say that is because i look
at somebody like you
who was born like i said with the joe
rogan
of the internet i see this burgeoning
alternative media ecosystem
i see sub stack i see what's happening
in silicon valley
with tech and so much more the explosion
of new businesses and more
and i say you know what there's
something going on here there's a
realignment so to speak right
and maybe what does the realignment
stand for is realignment
politics or it's everything it's see
that's that's the thing is
originally kind of began as politics we
were like oh well there's this
realignment where
i mean at the most basic sense it was
obama
voters then going to vote for trump like
in the political level
clearly something happened there
changing political coalitions then we
started talking about it
with bernie all this crossover between
bernie sanders voters and trump voters
same with your candidacy which is why i
was kind of obsessed with
because you ran and you had 42 percent
of trump voters who were supporting a
democrat
for the presidential nominee clearly
there's a cross-cutting message there
which is happening but the thing is the
more you look at it you have changing
business you know changing
media landscape changing business
landscape
you're changing political coalitions
it's like the craziest election in a
long maybe crazier than
the one before that so i kind of apply
it as a framework towards any
everything and that's what i mean when i
say i look at the media
and i know you're involved in the tech
space as well i see this explosion of
sub-sac i see this explosion of
independent journalists
guys like matt taibi joe rogan going to
spotify
the emergence of this whole new culture
and i'm like
what what we what it's really up to is
entrepreneurs and others
is to find a way in order to make that
work for local news and if that actually
cannot work
we truly cannot work i'm not above the
public solution
whatsoever it's more about jumping
towards that
a little bit too quickly if that makes
it it can't work brother
you know the numbers guy has looked at
and said this is a total disaster
and when when companies have invested
tens of millions in it you remember
patch yeah you know like it was just
setting money on fire
um the local papers have all become
you know desiccated husks or disappeared
and i walked through those offices
because i was campaigning in rural iowa
and new hampshire and elsewhere and so
you go interview with a local paper
and guess what that office looks like
now it's half empty and you know people
are
looking around wondering if they're
going to survive
and that's pretty pandemic i mean post
pandemic the stuff's even worse
you know can you imagine being like a
free weekly in austin or
boston or wherever trying to survive now
i mean it doesn't make any sense like
the the
you i am um
i'm sure that there is no uh
entrepreneurial market-based solution
um for local journalism unless you were
to have something like universal basic
income where
people had their needs met and then if
they wanted to they could write about
stuff
but even then you would have certain
types of journalism that were not
included in that
because like a local blog is not the
same as
having sure a genuine news organization
so well this is interesting because so
how what's your framework for looking at
it because
i mean you i mean i think i remember you
supporting democracy dollars
is would it be somewhere in the same
vein whenever it comes to media would it
be like you give x amount of money to
folks kind of like a ubi and then say
that you have to spend x amount
as on a subscription to a journalist or
a publication that you want or is it
that we would decide which publications
exist
yeah they like i'd like to give people
essentially media dollars or
journalism dollars and even then
unfortunately
i don't think it would necessarily solve
all of your problems and so i i think we
would need to subsidize local journalism
still because if i gave you
media dollars you might use it on a
bunch of podcasters and then there still
might not
be but but that is
the general approach uh because one of
the problems with our media coverage is
that
uh one and and here's the thing i want
you to
to know sagar and you're it's hard for
you to know this because you're
um uh you know still up and coming
uh but all the people you and i see are
already at like the top of the pyramid
you know what i mean sure
yourself included you know it's like
like if you say like oh well we you know
scrappy podcasts you like make this
stuff work and whatnot it's like yeah
some people can
you know but like but but it's not a
replacement
for uh what we're eliminating it's a
little bit like
like amazon to retail or whatever it's
like you know you're going to get rid of
whatever 10 million mall jobs then
you're going to end up with like 800 000
amazon employees
you know you're going to get you're
going to get rid of uh
you're going to get rid of a million
local journalists and then you'll have
like um you know
100 000 podcasters like only 20 000 of
whom can like buy health insurance
all right listen up i am personally
not a toilet paper guy we're going to
talk about some weird stuff i'm not a
toilet paper guy i'm more of a wipes guy
um but i've recently become
a bidet guy now what the hell's a bidet
i never heard of it i hadn't heard of it
so i went
um abroad and they have these in europe
but it's basically this lovely
warm hose
um that you use instead of toilet paper
to wipe your butt
and if they're extremely popular in
europe because they're cleaner
um you look there's not as much waste
there's less clogging
all this good stuff and there's a
company called
tushy that is making this more
accessible and easy for america
than americans to use so hello tushy
is the modern bidet attachment um it
cleans your butt with a
precise stream of fresh water for just
79 bucks so it attaches to your existing
toilet no electricity needed no
additional plumbing it cuts toilet paper
used by
eighty percent so if even if you're
trying to pinch pennies this is a save
um so the hello tushy bidet pays for
itself
in just a few months i love this because
it's better for the environment
it's modern it's smarter it's efficient
uh it's one of those things where other
countries have figured it out and
americans
are a little bit behind the curve on
this one but we can speed it up uh and
uh that's what we're all about here in
yang speaks
and this is one great way to do it be
kind to yourself be kind to the earth
so the yang speaks listeners gonna have
the cleanest butts in the country
this is a special offer for our
listeners hellotushy.com
for ten percent off hellotushy.com
yang
[Music]
the big problem i see is that we're also
conditioned
to just this sort of make it work
positive market mentality
that you'll see people making arguments
based upon like we'll adapt
like it's okay you can go to some local
newspaper and they'll be like well
adapted you'd be like you all are [ __ ]
you know it's like like that's like you
know that
i mean that that's like um it it's i
i've actually now
seen that that's one of the things
that's driving us to distress is like
there's this
uh disintegration of people's situations
but then they're they're being forced to
put on brave faces
uh yeah like you know like i've had so
many conversations that resemble that
um and the the issue really is that we
have this
this system-wide fabric that is tearing
in various
ways uh and we're not able to mend it
um and our organizations can't even
really talk about it because it's not
what they're measuring
i think you're right and i absolutely
agree which is that you know
hustle porn is kind of like what i like
to call it like hustle porn is not a
substitute
for like safety net or a government
society
which will actually ensure that the way
that you can live your life is
prosperous
or not and i think that that's actually
a really key point which is
the way i kind of see it is that after
2008
we basically pushed economic risk down
to the individual
like we we de-risked corporate the
corporate sector we de-risk you know the
financial sector and so much more
and it became incumbent upon others like
you and me well actually you're right
you know
we're already at the top so to speak it
came incumbent upon
everyone in order to have a little bit
of a risk and then
also bear a lot of the brunt of that
which i don't think is really fair
economically
but that kind of brings me to an
interesting thing here which is that
you've kind of zeroed in on local news
as a specific where
the government has to specifically prop
this thing up even
if we were to give people media dollars
i might go spend it on my podcasters
so to speak it runs a little counter
to ubi and the way that you look at it
because i think one of the reasons that
i'd always kind of raised questions
about ubi and
others had too which is that how do we
know that the money is necessarily going
to flow
to the sectors of the economy which we
know we need to prop up
the most or that we consider essential
as a nation-state
and that's kind of the framework that
you are adopting here with media
so i'm curious why it was your signature
solution
whenever it came to the economy
i've seen the folks who are struggling
around the country
and uh i have minimal interest in trying
to build up this
giant array of new government programs
that may reach
those hundred million people that just
don't care about any of it
uh you know you try and talk them into
it being like no this will be awesome
for you and they're just like
um and so i i thought
i still believe very uh
very confidently that putting resources
into people's hands would be the best
way to actually address
any of the other goals that you're
trying to address be it entrepreneurship
or small businesses health care
education
our political polarization putting in
money into people's hands be helpful for
all of it
and one of the frustrations i think
we're having and this is
from the math too it's like if you
increase everyone's costs by
200 to 250 percent gradually over time
um and you don't increase their income
in a real way
and you know they look around being like
why can i not send my kid to college
anymore without taking out like giant
debt like
why is daycare so crazy expensive what
like why
why are we um getting hooked on these
opiates while people profit to
billions of dollars from our addiction
no
they're just looking around saying um
this is getting worse and worse for me
uh and and the thing that i was so uh
i still get angry about is that like
there's a lot of like well it's somehow
your fault
you know and and it's uh it's like no
actually
it's the fact that we have allowed our
system
to become so inhuman and so
tilted towards the almighty dollar and
the corporations that make the dollars
as opposed to just the average uh
young man trying to make it or the you
know mom trying to figure out how to
provide a decent life
it makes you really sad and angry and
then if you look to try and solve that
uh the best thing you could do is put
money in their hands and then
like the money would end up guiding many
of our institutions and many of our
companies
toward uh trying to serve their needs
better
uh you know like it and this is one
thing that frustrates me about a lot of
people it's like you look up and you're
like okay things have gotten demented
over the last
uh let's call it 40 years uh
what one example uh you know might be
i mean you know freaking just pick an
example um
and then that there are people who want
to fix it
that just seem to be casting about for
different
solutions from the past uh and it's like
they think that we can dial back time
itself
to 1980 or that it's like there's like a
time sheet it's like no you know it's
2020 you look around
um the economy's turned on more and more
of us and turn us against each other and
we're all getting
uh stuck like rats in a maze
you know you get money into people's
hands and then it ends up alleviating a
lot of this
and there were these people who like i
was shocked sauger when i ran
i thought i'd be like the you know the
the guy who was even
um more radical than bernie or whatnot
like you know it's like even bernie
didn't take it this far
uh but but instead i wound up attracting
a totally different group of people
which i still find very invigorating and
exciting but there were people like
me and maybe to some extent you where
you're like oh this is like a different
approach to things like
this person seems more interested in
what the facts
are on the ground um and he doesn't
really want to waste any time like
attacking
you know like uh someone be it i and
what van says it's either immigrants or
billionaires depending upon which
part of the spectrum you're on it's like
i actually don't have that much of an
interest in throwing rocks at anybody
like
i'm just saying look here's a situation
it's terrible
for many many people it was terrible
pre-pandemic
here's how we can fix it uh
you know i'm curious on your side
because i regard you as an intelligent
conservative i feel like if i was an
intelligent conservative
you know that i'd have deep misgivings
about the current direction the
republican party
uh but but there there's like this
yeah this tough sense of um
you know of the fact that
that not many people have been living up
to the true ideals of conservativism in
my mind
oh i completely agree i mean i also
think that it's about the way that we
think about the word conservatism itself
i mean
the the truth is conservatism in my view
has i mean i also
have to tell these libertarians
libertarians actually i don't have a lot
in common with you i think it's been
hijacked
by libertarianism over the last 30 years
if you look at what we're trying to
conserve or what is conservative or what
does it even mean to pursue
economic conservative policy most people
unfortunately would say oh they're for
debts deficits
and better spending in government and
it's like well in my view
economic conservatism should be using
economic policy to achieve
conservative ends and when i mean that
what i mean by that
is i want to make it easier for people
to get married and have kids in this
country
and the number one reason in 2018 that
we had
lack of or we had the lowest marriage
rate of all time
was the number one reason that people
cited was not having the funds not
you know irreligiosity secularization
any of that which is something that is
erroneously blamed
by in my view like libertarian
conservatives
on they they try to blame people when in
reality it's what you're talking about
it's the
cruelty of an economic system which
makes it so that you are not
living up and making the choices that
you want to make i fundamentally believe
also in trusting people
and i think that by trusting people that
they will choose
almost generally in order to go in order
to take
and make choices that are best for them
which
all also align kind of what i mean when
i say economic conservatism
i'm incredibly excited that that's the
way you frame the challenge because i
agree that's the challenges like to me
if you don't have families like what's
the point and you know like
i'm a dad uh and i agree with you that
it's it should be a giant red flag to
all of us
if you have the lowest lowest marriage
rates because of economic
insecurity the lowest child bearing
rates because of economic insecurity
you talk to a young person and they look
up and say
i don't know if i'm ever going to be
able to settle down anymore and have a
kid because i can barely
like pay off my debt and keep a roof
over my head and like
you know and just be able to do my make
work
um uh stuff to make ends meet
um and i think that to me right now
our goal should just be human
flourishing and i agree with you that
most most all the time the best way to
have people flourish is to put the
agency in their hands
uh and let them make their own decisions
[Music]
there are a lot of creative people
listening to this right now i know it
i know the yang gang's filled with
creatives and one of the things
about trying to develop creatively is it
really really helps to have someone
who's further ahead
than you are on that skills chain if you
don't know what i mean you can teach
yourself a lot of stuff
but if you want some classes resources
world-class
experts skillshare is the place to go we
have
so many people who swear by skillshare
it's an online learning community with
classes for creative and curious people
you can do i mean you can't learn
everything but you can learn a lot of
[ __ ]
um and frankly with kovid
i've started to pick up golf a bit but
that's frankly i'm not very good so i've
started to find my like self-fulfillment
in other ways
so um you can learn literally like how
to illustrate
uh filmmaking from home how to be more
productive
um literally like there's like how to
draw different types of faces like it's
artistic it's life improving it's pretty
fascinating stuff and we have a special
deal for you guys
so if you want to explore your
creativity get two free months of
premium membership at skillshare.com
yang that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free get started and join today at
skillshare.com
yang that's two free months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes
at skillshare.com
[Music]
what i saw in trump what a lot of people
on my side saw
was this person opening the door and
kicking over
all of the people who define kind of
conservatism in the way that i was
talking about
and defining it as the love of free
markets very much like a mitt romney-ism
2012 makers and takers and demonizing
really people
who have been crushed by a neo-liberal
economic system
and so whenever i have my misgivings
like i'm
right now you and i are talking in the
midst of the rnc my misgiving
is that i see the gop straying away even
farther
over the last four years kind of since
the day that trump won
and the rnc kind of took it over and you
had these traditional conservative
elements and he didn't actually
live up as much to the the worker
promises that he made
during his campaign and similarly here
at the rnc
that to me what i want it to be is much
more like that 2016 campaign like i was
watching
um some clips of hillary clinton you
know defending
nafta and talking about you know jobs
and i know i know that it
in your view it doesn't always align
with trade but really what it
actually came down to it's not about
trading versus automation although we
can
you can discuss that it's about
compassion for
not lecturing these people and saying
that your
your life is better because we get you
know your job left here
and your life is still better or your
job left here and
it's now on you to move to an ex-urban
you know suburb and live in a smaller
town i mean the truth is i can't
remember which study i was
seeing this is again kind of comes back
to economic conservatism for me
which is localism you know a lot of
people really enjoy where they're from
and they want to live near their mom
and their grandparents and there's
nothing wrong with that saying you have
to move
is a terrible uh recipe that would get
rocks thrown at you in many many
american towns and deservedly so
i mean that to me if you're in the
wealthiest country in the history of the
world
it should not be that you have to uproot
yourself and your family to live a
decent life
uh now should we be encouraging dynamism
yes
uh you know but should we make it so
that if you choose not to move you die
no okay exactly right or or get hooked
on opioids or
and this comes down to monopolization
this is another something
i i'm really interested in which is that
one of the you know the deep
one of the most pernicious things that
somebody told me i won't name him
because he's high level in economics but
he said you know
i'm unconvinced that the best scenario
for amazon is
not 10 unemployment or you know perma 10
to 15
unemployment and the reason being that
if you're in a rural or a small town
that the best pa the best paying job so
to speak and really the only option for
you
is to work in an amazon warehouse at a
very set wage in a not which is
non-unionized
and there is a level of you know
corporate control there
over the way that you're conducting your
life and your you know
uni you your singular option
of being able to live that i do think is
unacceptable how do you how have you
always looked at the monopolization
question because i know you toyed with
it you know
between tech and in the regular sector
too
i don't think we have truly reckoned
with what it means to have
trillion dollar companies that dominate
so much
of our waking life uh you know and it
was
to me a source of great amusement
watching these trillion dollar companies
pretend to be scrappy startups in front
of congress the other week it was like
oh
you know we're not number one at all
we could be upended any day by those
tick tockers or whatever
it's like we wouldn't have crushed
instagram no like
you know it's like the whole thing i was
like oh yeah
like watching them uh try and recast
themselves
um yeah that
there are consequences of having
companies of that scale
are unknown to us
but they're extreme and one of the
things i kept saying to folks is like
look at this point
amazon no longer has to obey the rules
of business
physics anymore it's just like this
voracious black hole
literally you know it's like
it could decide not to make money in a
given quarter and it would still be
a trillion dollar company you can't
compete with them in any meaningful way
they have
uh essentially unlimited resources and
access to more data than anyone else
uh you know that like their they'll
trumpet the fact that they're hiring
tens of thousands of americans while uh
while retail is shutting down oh i mean
made light of it earlier about what's
going to happen
uh and and so the the old toolkit would
be like we'll break them up
and i think that there needs to be a
breakup of some of these companies in
some
verticals but i also don't think that
actually solves the problem
because you wind up with uh still
uh these network effects that just
advantage whatever company is
is at the hub and right now our
government is so bad at this
where we're essentially 25 years behind
the curve so any company that's come
into existence over the last 25 years
we're like don't know
like don't know what you're doing uh and
then we have this mistrust of government
being like well you're
slow and behind the times and they're
really smart
at times they should decide what to do
and and that that's been one of the ways
we're conditioned
uh so the optimal path would be
that we go to each of the big four or
five companies
and just say look we have company
specific issues with you
trying to apply a one-size-fits-all
antitrust framework doesn't even make
sense
right uh like we're gonna have to craft
tailored legislation
um and figure out what the worst aspects
of your
enormity are and then circumscribe them
so in facebook's case it might be like
well what are our biggest beefs with you
the the erosion or or
near decimation of our democracy i would
say would be the top of the list
and then the the fact that they sell and
resell us in our data for tens of
billions of dollars a year might be
second
then the third might be uh the fact that
they have a near monopoly on uh certain
types of social media because they did
buy instagram and whatsapp and so maybe
we have to
to do something about that and then
there there might be mental health of
our kids associated with instagram use
you go down the list and just trying to
figure out what what each issue
is um like i'm not against size for
sizes sake i'm against
size if it ends up hurting us in various
ways
and then you'd have to write
company-specific legislation
um for facebook essentially don't
pretend it's like we're going to take
out a 20th century
framework before the internet even
existed back when they were talking
about
you know picking like this company makes
too much steel
you know like it's a very very different
world now
yeah i think it's it's funny you said i
what i always loved about your
campaign was the feeling that i wasn't
living in ossified washington you know
like because i covered these guys on
capitol hill and so much more
and it was i'll never forget him being
like why does my
iphone listen to me and i was i was like
all right like when you're going up to
mark zuckerberg and you're asking
how does facebook make money it's like
okay i mean
you just waste you know you have a
finite amount of time whenever you get
to ask questions here
it used to drive me absolutely nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're listening to yang speaks you
like podcasts so thank you for that
but you also like learning from people
who
have done something become expert in
something
and one great podcast for that is the
jordan harbinger show
where he brings on folks who have become
world class at something
and then he doesn't just let them talk
about how cool they are he actually
tries to get into the guts
of how they do what they do so you can
pick up
how a cinematographer uh makes their
magic
how some of the greatest investors in
the world actually make decisions
uh how that guy from catch me if you can
conned so many people for years
so if these stories and the people
behind them
sound like that they would fascinate you
and edify you then the jordan harbinger
show
is the podcast for you this show
so one jordan's a pretty smart guy but
his guests are awesome he's got um he
has amanda knox on there recently who's
actually coming on
this podcast soon which i'm excited
about but investors like ray dalio he
just had an astronaut on to talk about
i mean what perspective um an astronaut
gets from once they come back to earth
he had guy razon from how i built this
who i'm a huge fan of
um and a big fan of that show so um and
then there's also a lot of practical
stuff that jordan teaches you so
how to fire somebody you care about is
an episode or things like
how do i work with deal with my
mother-in-law um so there's a lot of
crazy
but practical realistic stuff and you
can check it out
um wherever you can find podcasts so we
really enjoy the show and thank you
as well so search for the jordan
harbinger show
that's h a r b as in boy i n as in nancy
g e r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts
the jordan harbinger show check it out
we're fans you guys will be fans too
[Applause]
i'm actually curious how it's been for
you as you
have gone from this anti-establishment
figure to like now you're a cnn
commentator now you're a mainstream
i mean i would call you a mainstream
figure in the democratic party or at
least
a um established one so how has it been
like
the how have your ideas been received
because we talked about on the show at
the time like
at first they would laugh at you then
they would see you pass them in the
polls
then they would drop out and you would
still be on the stage and you know then
you would outraise them
then you would out pull them and it was
kind of a fun cycle
at what point did they start to take you
seriously and even now you know now that
the campaign is over
in what way how do they engage with your
ideas is it with sincerity
or is it with like a oh you know goofy
ideas
no politicians
uh respond to their own incentives and
so
politicians will be nice to you if for
example you have a mailing list of a
million people
and you and they know that you can uh
potentially be a value to them
[Laughter]
so so the the goal has to be that we
uh end up showing people that these
ideas are right but also that it's in
their interest to embrace these ideas
because it's good for them politically
and it's bad for them politically if
they don't uh you know that that's just
the
the way that their incentives run um in
terms of how i'm currently received
uh you know folks are constantly
congratulating me on the race
the campaign and at this point 55 of
americans are for universal basic income
and something like 76 are for cash
relief
so most people know that the ideas are
right
at this point um the question is to your
earlier
inquiry how the heck do you actually
have the will of the people
enacted by our legislators and that is
what i'm tasked with right now is
figuring out
how to rebuild that connection and make
it so that not only can we all know what
the right thing to do is but that our
lawmakers actually
pass it uh i you know
i'll say sagar it's like it you know i
agree with you that i have gone from
being something of a
fringe figure to a mainstream figure uh
by virtue of the math
it's like you know if you be if you have
a big enough following then you can't
really even define yourself as non
um not part of like the the mainstream
so thank you yang gang and thank you to
everyone who made that happen you
individually too sagar for always being
intellectually genuine uh and receptive
um but i still don't think that
like i'm considered part of the
establishment
um in in many respects i would say
certainly not the political
establishment i don't
live in dc i don't know a lot of the
people
um yeah so i mean from from my
perspective frankly i was running
and then the race ended and then kovit
hit and i've just been in my study
[Laughter]
so so it's hard to determine how
fundamental the transformation has been
well so tell me
what's your theory of the case on how
change is made i mean i
one of the ones and this this is an
elizabeth warren point but i've believed
this for a long time i've studied the
new deal
you know civil rights act so much more
like how this stuff actually
all came to pass at the end of the day a
lot of it was
what you referenced earlier earmarks
horse trading
and personnel more than anything it was
having
like a committed 100 to 1 000 people who
were well
versed in your ideology that were able
and also
qualified like well-educated qualified
all of that they were able to come in
and kick
the door in on day one whenever people
ask me why the trump presidency
didn't live up to its working ideals
that's that's my response which is that
look the establishment is the
establishment for a reason
they've got all the lawyers they've got
you know the the rnc
they've got these people who are like
very versed in their ideology
they're very good at it they've been
doing the same thing administration
after administration after
administration
they've got programs they've got
federalist society they've got
all these what i call them are
credentialing institutions
and you know when you're you're a
nascent political movement kind of how
i consider like the new right um you're
just not gonna have that
and i'm curious like how how have you
seen because
you like you're saying you know ubi
could be at 50 it could be a 100
approval rating
but if people on capitol hill don't
take it seriously um then it's not going
anywhere and it's
one of the most frustrating parts how do
you think that that
can be solved i mean do you even agree
with that like how do you think that you
can oh i agree with that for sure
yeah you know and and so for me
we need members of congress who ran on
it and who embrace it
uh and then you need to show other
members of congress that being forward
is better than
being not for it and then maybe you need
the blessings of some establishment
think tanks and whatnot to say yeah this
makes sense and this would work
but i agree with you you need to cross
each of those bridges to try and
get it across the finish line yeah and i
think that that's such an important
that's something i try and make my
listeners understand is i'm like what
you want
doesn't actually matter unless like
you have the infrastructure in dc in
order to actually
make that happen so last thing here
andrew i asked um
i asked my followers i asked a lot of
people i said what should i ask andrew
yang
the number one question that they wanted
to know was why you support biden
um and i wanted to give you a chance to
talk about it
no running for president you do get to
know the various candidates
um and i i think given the nature of
your audience
it's why do i support biden versus trump
i suppose seems to be the
yeah the question uh and i just don't
think trump has the right qualities to
govern
uh you know just think he's like a um
like a narcissist who uh doesn't have
the makeup doesn't have the right makeup
um and i think that so i'm not someone
that like there there are some people
who
um i who disagree with the fact that
american institutions have been failing
the american people for a long time i
think that's something you and i have in
common
and many trumpers have in common i 100
believe that
many of our institutions have been
failing us for quite some time and that
we have
been waking up to that increasingly uh
now i think that
certain americans have woken up to it
more than others there are some
americans who think that things are
working just fine
i'm not one of them and it's one reason
why
you know i think that there's been a gap
between me and certain other people
but i i just don't think that trump is
the figure you bring in
to uh make the right kind of changes
uh and i don't see eye to eye with joe
on everything
but having gotten to know joe i think
he's a fairly non-ideological
pragmatic guy who wants to try and find
the best path forward he'll have
really good people with and around him
and he's the best shot we have at trying
to actually get into the roots of some
of these problems
now speaking forthrightly i ran for
president
so i thought that i would be a great
choice
um but you know if you give me a choice
between donald trump and joe biden
it's going to be joe every day i mean
pretty utilitarian but i think a very
fair case to make anyway andrew i really
appreciate you joining podcast and
letting me on your podcast man it was a
great discussion thank you
oh sagar is a pleasure man and um thank
you for being one of the journalists who
always
had like like a real air of curiosity uh
and intellectual openness to my campaign
like that that's something maybe it's
your relative youth or maybe
um the fact that you're you know uh
asian american is as well where you saw
it's like huh like
or maybe just that you like facts and
figures i actually appreciated your
critique
um one of the things you wrote in your
book um about me was like hey is andrew
yang right about automation or is it
trade like i lean more towards
globalization but
you know like this is the kind of
conversation you should be having as
opposed to other nonsense
like that was actually one of the most
disciplined journalistic responses to
my campaign that i saw because and that
was one of the things that scared the
[ __ ] out of me
is like like people are having the usual
argument of symbols and then i come on
the scene and i'm like hey here's some
facts and figures
yep uh and the the level of journalistic
inquiry into my facts and figures was so
low
where like like there weren't many
people being like is this right
like did we indeed get rid of five
million manufacturing jobs like um
yes like what was the composition like
you actually went the step to say like
what was the cause of the loss of five
million manufacturing jobs and you were
like well
maybe it's this maybe it's that
certainly it's like a combination of
these things
like most journalists did just did not
seem to care to actually engage
um on that and then you have to ask
yourself wait a minute like let's say i
just changed the number
let's say instead of like we lost five
million manufacturing jobs we lost
ten yeah twelve like at what point does
it matter
to you yeah and uh and to most
journalists like it could be any number
and it just does not matter like that
they're not actually cataloging
uh the progress of our way of life
they're cataloging something else
um and that's what we have to change i
think you're absolutely right andrew
which is that
cataloging the day-to-day kind of ins
and outs palace intrigue of washington
is not even close to cataloging
trade automation the very way that we
structured live our lives
our standard of life to me it's all
about
that you know how healthy are we how
mentally healthy are we how are our kids
doing
how is our family formation rate uh no
like that that would be
probably like a very positive indicator
like
how addicted to substances are we how
optimistic are we
how dynamic are we culturally
economically are people starting
businesses
you know to me small businesses are the
life's blood of so many communities and
if you have
everyone just showing up to work at
amazon like that's kind of terrible
that's sort of dystopian
you know at some point amazon should
just start assigning us overalls and say
like hey you hear your amazon overalls
it's the american way it's got a big a
on the front you know
like uh we could be the united states of
amazon they could like take over the
flag maybe they pay enough they could
freaking sponsor our flag
[Laughter]
of uh i've gotten very dark and
dystopian but yeah
but but these but these are to me like
the right
you had some of the right questions and
you engage with them more
uh rigorously than most any other
journalist i saw honestly
thank you andrew really appreciate that
i appreciate you joining us man thank
you
no problem sagar it's great talking to
you you too thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yangspeaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you